Drive by day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day they get caught doing something.
But
yeah,
watch that.
And then,
sorry for interrupting that.
I've watched that hurt business documentary on Netflix with Danielle Carme aid,
the fucking like whatever this knee injury and is trying to get healthy again
and yeah,
fuck that documentary is and 10 she's got a watch.
It's so incredible.
Like the way,
I mean,
I almost like the focus of it is I get,
we're going to spotlight.
I'd like a a number of these personalities from the UFC and really short.
It's how fucking tragic it is.
They put so much into it and then the,
you know,
they had their careers for whatever it's worth.
And then when it's all said and done,
they just got nothing to fucking show for it and it's just so fucking trash.
Well,
you can't think that you're going to have something to show for it.
That's the thing.
If you're lucky and you become a Conor McGregor who is like one in a million or
you become,
you know,
a George St Pierre who retires as the champion,
you're,
you're really,
really unusual.
But for everyone else,
you have to do it because you love doing it of course.
And if you do it because you love doing it and that's what you want to do,
then you should do it and you will bank a lot of money if you're successful.
But there's this thing that people have when they see a guy like Floyd
Mayweather and they say,
well,
hey,
boxers make millions of dollars.
Look,
Floyd Mayweather made hundreds of millions of dollars.
No,
no,
no.
Floyd Mayweather makes hundreds of millions of dollars.
Not Boxers like Gennady Golovkin who was one of the best boxers in the world.
He can't even sell 200,000 paper views like his last paper of you by,
I think it was like 150,000 which is insanely low to the point where it's like,
it's very difficult for promoters to even get behind him unless he's finding
someone like Canelo Alvarez,
which is his next fight.
Well,
he'll make some money in that fight,
but guarantee you he ain't making very good money like with 150,000 paper views
and he's a multiple time world champion and like an fantastic amateur fighter
and one of the best in the world.
It's about being a star and a promoter is not responsible to give a fighter a
bunch of money if they're not earning a bunch of money.
It's a business and the business is people want to pay to see you.
Why do they want to see you?
Do they want to see you because you trash talk or do they want to see you
because you're Anderson Silva and you fight like you're in,
you're in the Matrix?
Or do they want to see you because you're Ronda Rousey and the first ever woman
ass kicker that we've ever seen like this?
Well,
whatever reason it is that they want to see you.
That reason is why you can make a shit ton of money.
It's not that you just deserve a shit ton of money because it's hard to do.
And that's where,
but a lot of people get that wrong in their head.
They get that wrong in their head.
Well it's show business,
but it's also athletics.
So it's a very bizarre combination of two worlds.
Do you think that Karma Gregor is doing a disservice to south by putting so much
attention on like just putting his whole UFC career on hold for this Mayweather
thing?
No.
Um,
because ultimately he can only fight for so long and he stands to win.
Like who knows how much money.
I mean he can make,
it could be as much as a hundred million dollars.
The fight,
it's going to be insane.
Asking a guy to pass up on the opportunity to make $100 million is kind of
crazy.
That said he's fighting boxing.
No it doesn't.
No,
it doesn't matter.
It's not,
the way boxing works is you get a purse.
You know,
like the way UFC works is different and often criticized and I think rightly so
is that you have a wind money and a show money.
So say if you were going to fight Jamie and they set it up where you uh,
you fight,
you make $50,000 to show and then another 50 if you win.
A lot of people have a real hard time with that and I think they should because
you're doing your best,
you're giving your best performance regardless of whether or not you win.
No one's going to fight harder,
I don't think,
at least to be,
to get that wind bonus.
These guys are trying to win their fucking gladiators,
you know?
I mean I think you should have a purse and that should be what you get paid and
you fight your best and that's what you get paid.
Like this idea that you're,
that's double is going to,
you know,
you're going to come your way if,
if you get the judge's nod.
Meanwhile the judges get shit wrong all the time and to have your future like
have $50,000 or 100,000 or who knows what the number is on the line due to
someone else's interpretation of it.
Or You can get injured and wind up losing or anything.
Had happened.
Like I think that's kind of fucked up.
The thing about the Conor McGregor Floyd Mayweather fight.
If it's tennis,
you'd get the money if you win.
Yeah,
but that's different.
First of all,
it's not a fight.
Okay.
Cause like you can play a tennis match every weekend.
Try fighting every weekend.
We'd be dead in a month.
You know a cure is US president.
Yeah.
They agreed to sign a deal with Floyd.
That doesn't mean anything because Floyd Mayweather has an agreed to it.
The deal has been negotiated.
Connor has agreed.
So that's what that means.
But here's the deal.
Let's be honest about this as much as possible.
This is a boxing match between Conor Mcgregor,
a guy who's never had a real professional boxing match.
It was a really good amateur boxer in Ireland who's a real multiple division
world champion combat sports fighter.
No doubt about that.
But,
and a striker,
no doubt about that.
But it's fighting one of the best boxers,
if not the best boxer ever.
Most likely does not going to work out well for him.
If you had to guess.
That's my honest take on it.
The only way it could work out well is if Floyd takes him lightly.
Connor clips him Connor mugs and kind of does some like old school Bernard
Hopkins Shit like ties him up.
Rob some up inside the clinch,
hits them with some real hard shots or,
or does something fucked up to them.
I mean who knows.
Headbutts I mean that's where Victoria Doherty's tried to do with him.
I guess he can also say that,
um,
that uh,
he doesn't really stand there.
It's,
it's win win for kinder.
Cause if he loses his,
of course he was going to lose.
Yeah.
And also Floyd is not a vicious puncher.
Floyd's not knowing.
Never was.
No,
no.
He never was.
He,
he is an amazing boxer,
but he is very brittle hands.
He breaks his hands a lot and he can knock you out like you knocked out Victoire
tease.
But he knocked out Victoria.
He's cause he's just standing in front of him.
He knocked out Ricky Hatton who was a smaller fighter,
but he doesn't knock out most guys.
He stuns them.
He sticks them with some hard shots,
but conn has got a really good chin and he's a much bigger guy so the odds are
if even if Connor gets worked,
he's just going to get out boxed for 12 rounds and get embarrassed and just with
at a bunch of punches and Floyd is not going to be anywhere near him or he can
catch him.
I mean it is possible that he can catch him but it's not likely like the odds
are going to be huge in Floyd Mayweather.
His favor.
If I had a gas it's we're going to be like 20 to one or something crazy like
that.
I'm not an oddsmaker but,
but I do know movement and I know boxing and that just just,
just a big difference between what a guy like Floyd Mayweather can do and a guy
like Conor can do when it comes to the actual boxing skills.
But there's also,
there's another factor too that Connor has been fighting with small gloves and I
was going to be fighting with larger gloves.
What size gloves they agree on for the fight.
If Floyd smart,
he's going to make him fight with 10 ounce gloves,
you know,
cause probably Connor will want and why where eight,
I dunno what,
what weight class?
They have the cutoff in like lighter weight classes.
They use eight ounce gloves and Le Heavier these 10 ounce gloves,
you know,
that's,
that's like that was a stipulation in the Marvin Hagler sugar ray Leonard fight
the sugar ray Leonard,
one of the bigger gloves on a heavier gloves because he's fighting a big heavy
puncher like Hagler.
So they might make some sort of a decision to go with larger gloves.
But Floyd's a fucking 49 in oh multiple division world boxing champion and
Connor has never had a professional boxing fight.
That's really what it is.
It's interesting.
I mean I want to see it.
Don't make no mistake about it when the fucking first bell rings.
I'll have my popcorn ready,
bro.
Well you'll probably be right there.
I don't think so.
No,
I think I'll be home.
Yeah,
I think it'd be watching that from home.
I think that's a,
whoever does commentary on that.
It's going to be probably boxing people.
It's like if you had Max Kellerman and Jim Lampley doing,
um,
commentary on Floyd Mayweather fighting Conor McGregor and an MMA fight,
I think that would be an embarrassment.
That'd be ridiculous.
Just as ridiculous as it would be for me to do commentary on Connor Fighting
Floyd in a boxing match.
Unless they wanted to have a combination of an MMA judge and a,
or an MMA,
a commentator,
and a box and commentator.
Maybe.
Perhaps I would do it with Max Kellerman.
I'm a big fan of that guy,
like that guy a lot.
I think that'd be kind of interesting,
but most likely I'll be at home watching it.
You know,
I'd like to see it live.
Maybe,
maybe sit ringside.
We'd be kind of interesting to see that.
It's going to be a crazy,
interesting experience to see what Connor can do.
And I know he's been working like almost exclusively on his boxing for months
and months and months in preparation for this.
Here's the thing that mother fucker can put you into orbit with one punch.
That's a fact.
You know,
like if you look at this past weekend is a perfect example.
When I said I'm about Eddie Alvarez and Dustin poray having this crazy war,
Connor new murked bolted,
those guys with one punch with,
I mean with Eddie,
he softened him up with a few punches before he marked him,
but he had them on Queer Street with one punch and he marked Dustin Poirier with
one punch.
I mean,
he's just,
he hits fucking hard.
This,
this guy for Rasa hobbies,
a very famous MMA coach and he said it best.
He said,
Connor has a touch of death.
Like he just,
he just fucking,
he just blacks.
Dude's in Zap some with ridiculous speed and accuracy and when he does your
Foxville,
the question is whether or not it can be able to do that to Floyd motherfucking
Mayweather and most likely Ford's going to be nowhere near him when those
punches come flying.
I mean,
he's a wizard.
You ever watch like Floyd Mayweather defensive highlight reel when it's just him
kind of running backwards?
No,
him just moving away from punches,
bending at the hips.
He's not a runner.
See Fluid.
People think of Floyd's or runner.
Floyd doesn't run.
He's not like running away from God's,
he stands right in front of Dude's.
He stands right in front of Dude's and maybe backs up slightly or moves to the
side.
But he's just so knowledgeable when it comes to boxing and he has such a deep
understanding of where to be at the right time and where the punches can come
from.
The left comes from here,
that means a rights coming this way and he's nowhere near that.
He's over here.
And that means after the right look like what can you stand in front of them?
You when you watch him,
the way he's able to like slide out of the way a shit.
I mean dudes just don't fucking hit him very often.
He's been hit least or less than any world champion that's had 49 fights.
I would say that he probably has the most successful defensive career and the
history of boxing.
He's,
I mean,
he's literally been tagged hard maybe five,
six times it his entire career and he stands in front of some of the best
fighters in the world.
Like Canelo Alvarez mean Canelo was younger then.
It was a few years ago and Canelo wasn't as good as he is now,
but he just stands right in front of guys and pop them in the face and just
understands how to move like that kind of shit.
Like when you're watching this highlight reel,
you're watching a master like young fighters.
They should,
they should watch his defensive movements and abilities I think almost above all
others,
except now this new guy,
facility Loma Chanko,
who I think his rivals,
anybody that's ever lived in terms of his movement,
his ability to move and his,
his positioning and footwork.
I think he's as good as it's ever been,
but you know,
he is only got like nine professional fights or something like that.
He just hasn't really,
luckily this Oscar de la Hoya standard right in front of him and he can't
fucking hit him.
He's thrown all these punches like that.
Mom won my mail Marquez,
he pops them in.
Just swooped slides right out of the way.
Sorry.
Not here.
An unbelievable work ethic.
Like Floyd Mayweather.
We'll go to a club,
go to a nightclub in Vegas,
hang out,
drink water,
hang out with everybody,
get all the accolades.
There's a gentleman floored bullying may,
whether somebody goes crazy lights,
some hundred dollar bills.
Dan,
you know what he does?
People will drive his Rolls Royce and he'll run,
he'll run the Vegas strip but run miles and then go to the gym three o'clock in
the morning and do fucking 15 rounds in the heavy bag.
He's an animal.
I mean his,
his work ethic and his mind and his determination and focus.
And I guarantee you man,
if he's getting ready for,
for Floyd Mayweather is getting ready for um,
Conor McGregor.
He's got to be in tip top shape again man.
He's not,
he's never going to come in and slept in.
It's going to be fun.
But why is he got to be so such a Dick?
Yeah,
cause that's how I made all that money.
It's because we were talking about before.
Like what it like a show business,
the show business aspect of it is having Pete like he used to be pretty boy
Floyd Mayweather.
That's the eastern calm but it wasn't really making any money.
You know,
he became rich when he became Floyd money Mayweather when he started talking all
this shit and then people want him to get his ass kicked and he wasn't getting
his ass kicked.
Like people paying to see him.
Not necessarily because they like it,
they're paying to see him cause they want to see him get fucked up cause he's a
huge star and it became a huge star by fucking with people talking a lot of
shit.
Talking about how great he is showing all of his watches and all this jewelry
and all.
He's got this crazy house in Vegas and you know,
I mean it's the,
it's really the controversy like domestic violence through went to jail for
beating up girls.
You know like there's a lot of controversy involved in him and that's one of the
reasons why people wanted to see him fight.
They want to see him lose and he didn't lose.
He went all the way to the bank.
I mean,
he tied rocky Marciano's record for having the most successful fights ever.
49 and l as a champion.
It's not unheard of.
Unheard of.
And Rocky Marciano's records bullshit because rocky Marciano Italians right now
going crazy.
What the fuck is Cya and rob caged up badge.
It's pretty much agree that rocky Marciano fought his brother and at least one
fight early in his career.
So it was like a fake fight to pull that up.
See if you've,
that's been,
that's been validated.
I'm pretty sure I've read that,
that rocky Marciano had like a fixed fight with his brother.
Like back in the day,
you know,
like a guy like rocky Marciano was a murderous puncher.
It's probably like he would show up for fight and people didn't want to fight
him.
And I'm like the people that paid to see him,
like,
what are we going to do?
I'm like,
damn,
my brother would get in there.
So his brother gets in there and goes down to a body shot or something.
I Dunno.
I Dunno how it played out,
but.